I've talked about meeting Sean Hannity
conservative radio host in the past and
I've admitted that despite finding his
politics totally deplorable disgusting
of the many liberal and conservative
media people that I've met he was one of
the nicest he hangs around the longest
talking to people who want to talk to
him or take a picture to get an
autograph apparently though that doesn't
apply to everyone that Sean Hannity
meets because it's been leaked that Sean
Hannity once pulled out a gun on liberal
Fox News contributor Juan Williams in
October after getting into a political
debate with Williams on-air Hannity
pulled out a gun and pointed it right at
Williams according to three different
people with direct knowledge of the
incident and Hannity imagine this was
even using the laser sight on the gun so
a red dot a red laser dot appeared on
Williams's body on the set of Fox News
sources say that maybe Hannity was kind
of joking but that everybody in the room
was very disturbed by what happened
including Williams himself other people
in the room reported the incident to
higher-ups at Fox News and to the legal
and human resources department that were
ultimately notified about this it's not
clear what came of it a Fox News
spokesperson asked about this said quote
Sean Hannity has been trained in
firearms safety since he was 11 years
old and has a license to carry a gun in
five states including New York the
situation was thoroughly investigated
and it was found that no one was put in
any danger
Hannity was asked about this as well and
he said via the spokesperson quote while
discussing the issue of firearms I
showed my good friend Juan Williams my
unloaded fire on in a professional and
safe manner for educational purposes
only
every precautionary procedure that I
have been trained in since the age of 11
was followed I've had a concealed carry
permit in five states for all of my
adult life any other interpretation of
this is outright false reporting
pointing a gun at someone is pretty high
on the list of gun safety things that
you should never do even though he
believes the gun to be unloaded you
don't point a gun at someone so how can
the reports all say he pointed the gun
at Williams putting a laser sight on him
and yet followed all safety precautions
right and compute whether the guns real
or fake whether
loaded or unloaded you shouldn't do that
because you're causing the other person
to have fear for their life and even if
you're thinking selfishly what if Juan
Williams had a gun on him and thought he
was threatened yeah
pulled out his gun of his own and
someone gets shot in that case I mean
even from a selfish perspective and you
not think about the other person you
just shouldn't do that out of your own
safety also how is it that all that fox
news has to say about one of their
employees pointing a gun at another one
of their employees is that all safety
measures were followed there aren't that
many employers who would react to one
employee drawing a bead with a red laser
on another employee in their office
space most employers would not react in
this way would they I don't think so I
mean I think it's just that Juan
Williams is often thought of as the
token liberal on the show there yeah
it's okay - oh my god Adam yes okay with
that I mean how insane is that it can
you imagine it's only Juan Williams he's
here just to provide a liberal
alternative view to the 99% view if if
it had been yet I don't even know Brian
Kilmeade who had a gun pointed at him
this would be a very different situation
Hannity one of the earliest prominent
figures in corporate media to support
Donald Trump seems to love confrontation
of all kinds whether it's on Twitter or
in studios I wonder how common it is for
people to pull guns out at Fox News I've
been there twice and in New York City I
didn't see any guns and so I have no
idea how common of a thing it is well
you should have one of your own just in
case that was to happen right only way
to stop Fox News with the weapon is when
I have a weapon yourself yeah very very
strange story folks